hey everyone it's my photos and this
week I'll be giving a live webinar on
order flow X JPMorgan futures trader
explains order flow everybody come nah
but seriously my name is my vatos and
yeah I spent eight years trading at
JPMorgan among other places I've been at
other firms Cargill Commerce Bank ETF
Mann and even on the CNE floor but I'll
be giving a presentation this Thursday
October 19th with investor inspiration
it's part of their pro trader series
workshop and you see this is my my
picture right here so I'll be speaking
at 2:45 again it's on starts Thursday at
11:00 a.m. Eastern Time it goes until
4:15 Eastern Time I'm sort of on the
afternoon afternoon schedule so you
could sign up go to order flows calm
slash sign up that HTML or you can click
on the link below in the description
it's there for you now there's two links
there's one where you could sign up
through my website or you could sign up
through the investor inspiration link
it's the same it takes you to the same
place same sign up so it's not like you
know one or the other
some people say oh I'm so confused
because you got two signups no it's
actually the same but you know some
places like YouTube they don't want to
have a big long URL that you know people
got to sign up for and it's kind of hard
to put the whole investor inspiration
link in here so you just go to this this
page and I'll just take you to the sign
up page so what will I be talking about
I will be talking about how to read
order flow to find better trains right
as a trader you always want to be
finding good trades right you don't want
to be finding crappy trades and order
flow is is a way that you can find good
trades you know it sounds easier said
than done you know we all want to find
good trades right and I'm going to show
you how to use order flow to find those
good trades trading with institutional
order flow now you know a lot of people
say oh you got to go with the big money
I do what the big money is doing and
follow the big money but they don't
really tell you how to tell what the big
money is doing and I say that that's a
bit disingenuous when they say do what
the big money is doing because you don't
know what the big money is doing you
don't know if they're getting into a
position getting out of a position so
you know if you are a swing trader and
institutional's institutions are doing
something you know it may one count
- what you're seeing on a swing chart so
you know order flow I think is best used
on a very short time frame intraday you
know anywhere between the next print
until you know 30 minutes to an hour I
don't really advocate trading order flow
on a long-term basis you know you're
based in your trading decisions on the
trades that are you know the orders that
are coming in and being traded in the
market now you know and so the market is
constantly evolving and it's always
changing so you know information that
was useful an hour ago is probably not
that useful right now I mean there's
different scenarios different situations
but again y'all don't talk a bit about
trading with the this this whole phrase
trading with institutional order flow
you know the good points and the bad
points I mean it sounds great oh yeah
you know the institutions they make
money they've been around in for a long
100 's of years they've got deep pockets
so that's who you should be trading with
but you know there's caveat stew it
there's caveats to its leave it at that
for now I'll show you how using an order
flow you can identify trap belongs and
shorts in the market right what you want
to be doing or is you want to have an
edge over people and when traders are
trapped in a position what I mean is you
know they're long and wrong as soon as
you know we've all been in those
positions as soon as you click buy the
market sells off your long and wrong
right or you got short in the market
rallies two points against you you're
screwed and I'm going to show you how to
use order flow to identify when traders
are in those trapped positions you know
that's everyone talks about having an
edge in the market and when you can
identify when people are trapped in a
position and need to get out that's
going to give you a slight edge over
over other people you know they'll give
you an edge over the traders that are
trapped but it'll give you an edge in
the sense that you could get in really
quick and you know get what you can out
of the trade you know from you know a
couple ticks to a couple points
depending on the market you're trading
and I'm going to show you how to use
order flow to find hidden the support
and resistance now you know everyone
talks about support and resistance and I
see I see these people posting up these
charts all the time you know the bar
chart they're drawing support resistance
lines and it's just like oh okay keep
doing that
you know because you know you're that
fresh money that's gonna be coming into
the market for you know the people that
know how to use order flow and find the
real hidden support and resistance
market and what our he didn't support
resistance markets it's it's watch the
webinar and I'll tell you but basically
it's you could see it it's it stands out
in the order flow okay and again you
know why people don't use order flow in
their training analysis is beyond me I
mean it informations out there right
it's there for you it reminds me back in
the days of when I was in high school
right I hated to study I'll be the first
to admit I hated it and you know I my
friends you know it always ace their
exams you know get straight A's and you
know guy one kid two of my friends Frank
first and second they would alternate
you know between first and classes and
second in class you know new report card
would come out one would be on top the
other one would be second and vice versa
on the next one and and there you know
our GPA or grade point averages on a 4.0
scale so and these guys were like taking
advanced classes and stuff so there's
like four point two three seven eight
two you know they would go out to like
three or four decimals to find out who
is who is it above them all right guys
what's your secret how do you do it how
you do it and guy just hold up his book
says all your information is right here
you know look at it you know it sounds
simple and you know if again yeah you
can have the information in front of you
not everybody uses it right so it's not
brain surgery is is the point so now if
you can't attend this webinar it's free
but if you can't attend at least
register because then you could get on
the distribution list to be emailed a
link to the replay when it is available
okay now cuz I know again I'm speaking
at 2:45 Chicago time I'm sorry 2:45 New
York Times so that's one forty five
Chicago time and again I realize you
know that's schools ending on for some
people or you're working you can't
attend but that's fine you can just you
know sign up for it and least then
you'll be aware of where to go to watch
the replay when it's available it
usually takes a day or two I said this
is Thursday so I don't put out the
distribution I don't release the the
link to it the last time is actually
streamed live on YouTube
as well so you're able to go to YouTube
afterwards but I think they restrict it
you know to the replay they're watching
it you know it's a private link so you
got to sign up for it now again you know
disclaimer you know I don't want people
coming in thinking that I'm going to
show them the secret to the market it's
the holy grail to the markets it's it's
not you know trading takes work and so
you know these presentations and even
this video again yeah I gotta put a
disclaimer on this individual video even
though I'm not really talking about much
it's for educational informational
purposes only and should not be
considered a solicitation to buy or sell
a futures contract or make any other
type of investment decision futures
train contain substantial risk and is
not for every investor and investor
could potentially lose all in more than
the initial investment risk capital is
money that can be lost without
jeopardizing one's finances security or
lifestyle only risk capital should be
used for trading annoy those with
sufficient risk capital should consider
trading past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future results
so again go to the link below or go to
my website order flows comm slash sign
up at HTML and it'll take you to the
sign up link and I hope to see you guys
there
on Thursday I you know I'll probably
covering some stuff in here that I
haven't covered in any of my previous
webinars but you know again it's it's
it's free doesn't cost anything except
your time and you ask yourself you know
is it worth 45 minutes of my day to
watch this guy or listen to this guy
rather I think it is so anyway have a
great day and I'll see you guys there on
Thursday bye bye